centuries of tradition go into any royal
wedding
they include Myrtle that's grown in
Queen Victoria's garden for the
traditional royal wedding bouquet those
flowers by the way are laid at the Tomb
of the Unknown Warrior in Westminster
Abbey there's also the rare goal that's
been used in royal wedding bands for
nearly 100 years you know what right now
let's head to the long walk about a mile
and a half from here Jonathan Vigliotti
is on the final stages of the carriage
procession route that Harry and um Megan
Markel will take tomorrow he had a
unique access to the remote Welsh mine
that's produced the gold for decades
Jonathan good morning good morning
you've probably never heard of Welsh
gold it's some of the most expensive on
earth incredibly difficult to find and
we had a one-of-a-kind tour of this site
where this royal wedding tradition began
hidden in these hills past Wales version
of a guard dog is the unlikely vault of
a royal wedding tradition geologist
Howard Baker with album mineral
resources took us on a claustrophobic
journey to the bedrock hiding Welsh gold
some of the rarest on earth and a
favorite of the British monarchy you can
say the court finding in the and it's in
those veins that you'll find the gold
for almost a century the royal family
has turned Welsh gold into wedding bands
beginning with the Queen's mother Queen
Elizabeth continued the tradition
followed by Prince Charles and Princess
Diana even modern royal Brides like the
Duchess of Cambridge where Welsh bands
for this ring I thee Wed so we're
looking at the beginning of a tradition
here and the beginning of an industry
it's believed gold was first discovered
here at the klog I mine in the Bronze
Age but commercial mining didn't begin
until the mid-1800s and only produced
about 3 tons before closing in the 1990s
today some of the remnants of the Welsh
gold mining industry have been turned
into a modest Museum managed by the
National Trust's Bethany Fenn
why would the Royals fall in love with
Welsh gold when it's so much harder to
find instead of gold that is more
readily available well it's in the
question itself you know it's so hard to
find I mean the Queen on her 60th
birthday she got gifted a kilogram of
this Welsh gold and she's been slowly
chipping away at it with all these
wedding rings ever since it's unknown
how much Welsh gold
the Queen has left to chip away from so
you're saying the royal family could
have some of the last Welsh gold
currently out there on the market they
could have one of the last major sources
are Welsh gold we have an it which is
where Howard Baker re-enters the gold is
right where we are it's underneath us
yeah we're walking on gold pretty much
yeah and the hills and gold and all
those Baker's company is planning to
reopen the mine and unlock the royal
treasure inside bringing an industry
back to life and also creating many more
wedding rings in the future Gayle all
right Jonathan Vigliotti thank you I
have to say I'd never heard of Welsh
gold but that's the thing that CBS this
morning learned something new every day
covered something new every single day I
think so thank you Jonathan